hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen app
vorstellung und zwar von der app land
weil ich kann das erklären
es hat nicht süß wir spielen heute die
app länder pirates was so ähnlich
vergleichbar ist mit gleich auf kleins
eigentlich ist genauso wie gleich oft
lernt so sieht das ganze spiel von enden
aus und wir können hier auf den hello i
button
jeder mal kurz die daraus also das spiel
ist eigentlich wirklich so aufgebaut wie
gleichauf kleines wir haben hier ein
hauptgebäude dass es unser
piratenversteck wir haben hier die
goldlager und die grog lager also es
gibt zwei verschiedene substanz in
diesem spiel hast du nämlich einerseits
das grob und einerseits das gold mit
denen kann man verschiedene sachen
machen sollte es eigentlich für alles da
was man irgendwie sowas wie kann nun
kann man mit gold ausbauen irgendwelche
moerser hier irgendwie dem
piratenversteck und mit gott kann man
halt zusammen machen wie die goldlager
ausbauen beispielsweise oder dinge
machen die piraten anheuern oder piraten
ausbilden oder wenn ich hier
beispielsweise auf ausbilden clique dann
kann ich irgendwie meinen hexendoktor
upgraden in den fertigkeiten ich glaub
ich muss halt ja spinn ich großartig
erklären ich glaube viele spielen das
auch als in den app store charts relativ
weit oben ist unter umsatzstärkste weil
es eigentlich genauso aufgebaut ist wie
clash of trance mehr oder weniger
brauchen jetzt nicht in die kommentare
schreiben
musikalischer fans ich finde es
allerdings ein bisschen cooler als
ketchup lens weil zumindest auf dem ipad
ist sie gab jetzt nicht sooo geil aber
auf dem iphone 6 was hier habe die
grafik echt extrem cool man kann das
ganze aus allen richtungen so betrachten
wir anbei anschaue anschauen angucken
bleiben das ist auch irgendwie voll cool
also ich finde die grafik cooler hier
laufe nicht so kleine männchen rom also
ich weiß becker schaffte sind viele
elemente davon auch enthalten aber ich
finde es wirklich irgendwie cooler und
vor allem bei mir war es so weit
geschafft herzlich war einer stelle
angekommen wo ich mir gesagt habe okay
jetzt muss ich wirklich immer bis
irgendwas ausgebautes 23 tage warten
eine woche warten
das heißt da muss man einfach sehen dass
kaufmann das spiel gut spielen wenn und
hier ist es wirklich so zurzeit ist es
bei mir noch so dass sie beispielsweise
15 stunden die goldmine hier in einen
bunker braucht noch fünf stunden das ist
noch auszuhalten etwa
ich denke auch dass sie mir diese spiele
in zwei drei wochen keinen spaß mehr
machen wird aber ich wollte einfach mal
an zocken weil ich finde wenn ich dieses
spiel schon die ganze zeit so spielen
dann kann ich dir davon bei youtube
hochladen wo ich einfach zeigen was ich
dann immer so machen wenn ich da drin
natürlich ist es jetzt kein spiel wie
ihnen wie make the jump oder wie 3 oder
wii geometrie dass ich wirklich die
ganze zeit spielen kann und alles
möglich wenn ich langweile sondern es
geht eher darum wenn ich in die app
rheingauer ich mir ein paar piraten hier
ist beispielsweise noch einen platz dann
packe ich mir da mal ein freibeuter rein
das ist der schlechteste der piraten ich
habe den schon ganz gut gebildet weil
man hat hier wo habe ich die hier hat
man diese piraten aus bildungsanstalt
und da kann man hier auch fertigkeiten
klicken dann kann man die upgraden mit
sachen wien schadens bonus oder was auch
ganz geil ist es dass lisa berserker
dann werden die für kurze zeit stärker
das habe ich für alle hier schon gemacht
auch für meine lieben die kann zum
beispiel anja die eigenschaft dass sie
schnell irgendwelche ressourcen gebäude
ausrauben kann die beispielsweise einen
grog goldmine oder lager und ja ich
würde sagen also meine schenk ist jetzt
voll also ich habe hier wirklich 35
schenken plätze einige leute wie
beispielsweise hier verbraucht dann nur
einschenken platz andere wie er warum
verbrauchen viel schenken plätze und ich
hoffe ich habe schenken uns nichts
schenken gesagt diego wechsel steht ist
eigentlich mein schiff meinen
piratenschiff ihr seht aber wenn ich
hier auf die landkarte clique seht ihr
schon was auch richtig cool designten
finde ich als ich in das design echt
cool
dann ist mein schiff länger unterwegs
hat auf eine andere flotte getroffen die
das sogar meine flotte unter schwimmbad
durch moderate durch die moderate sie
ihr seht hier oben rechts eingeblendet
eine stunden und 37 minuten brauchen die
noch und so habe ich meine karte bisher
schon erkundet und da findet man dann
auch so sachen wie beispielsweise hier
eine runde insel wenn ihr die mal seht
da ist jetzt gerade nicht aber dessen
goldschatz beispielsweise drauf und hier
ist auch ein goldschatz da wenn ihr den
seht moment seit jahren gold schätzen
das sind beispielsweise verbündete von
mir mehr oder weniger das heißt wenn ich
reingehe kann ich mir dann von dem
bisschen gold abholen
und da sind kleine piraten bisschen auf
reise unterwegs allerdings können wir
auch einfach mal plündern gehen und
gegen einen rivalen kämpfen weil ich
gerade kein schild habe er ist mir ein
bisschen zu hart das muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen der hat zwar relativ gute
maximale beute die man kriegen kann
allerdings sind die mauern mir echt zu
krass und diese kann ohnehin schon
relativ gut gearbeitet ich glaube da
werde ich richtig doll verpacken
ich denke nämlich ich denke das ist ganz
cool also das ist dass es so
heute gegen dich oft angreifer hat nur
einen mörser da kann ich dann direkt auf
dem moerser gehen zeige ich euch mal wie
ich ihr vorgehen und zwar nehme ich
jetzt eigentlich immer diesen starken
hier
das ist echt der aller stärkste also
beim iphone ist es wirklich so die teile
haben dann noch ein schatten und alle
diese ganzen gebäude dann ist das
eigentlich immer relativ cool weil das
dann doch von der grafik komplett anders
aussieht aber guckt diese fünf sechs
leute ihr diese stätten die wenn die
einmal drauf und kupfer hier lag das
gebäude ist nahezu direkter und deswegen
diese kleinen nämlich dann ihr so im
hintergrund hier
wenn ihr diese kleinen mit der pistole
da sehen die dinge im hintergrund so ein
bisschen vor hinten sich jetzt
beispielsweise ist noch niemand da packt
einfach mal diese drei hierhin gibt den
direkten berserker dass ein bisschen
schneller am start sind
und dann sehe ich auch schon dass hier
das erste lager am start ist es weil das
heißt ich packe ich erstmal vier
diebinnen hin
die da hingehen allerdings die diebinnen
sind immer so ein bisschen anfällig für
schüsse deswegen pack ich hier sollen
hexendoktor hin
er geht dann zu den hier seht schon
diesem kreis und dann wären die im
umkreis immer so ein bisschen geheult
denke das gleiche da setze ich hier
jetzt noch einen weil der bewirbt sich
dann zu dieser truppe hier bewegen die
auch schon relativ ko sind also die
werden davon jetzt nicht aufgefüllt
sondern die werden einfach so ein
bisschen so ich weiß nicht genau wie ich
das sagen dabei so ein bisschen halt
wenn die angeschossen werden kriegen die
nicht so viel leben abgezogen sage ich
mal
und so läuft dann quasi den kampf ab
also ich hab das eigentlich schon ich
bin so in dem spiel quasi drin dass ich
wirklich am anfang schon sagen okay da
setze ich die hin da setze ich ihnen da
setzt sich die hin und dementsprechend
ist es dann so dass ich nicht alle
direkt auf einen punkt mache aber
relativ alle relativ schnell
hintereinander
viele werden das wahrscheinlich auch
anders machen von euch jeder spieler
spielen ich denke ich denke eigentlich
dass viele airlines bleiben werden aber
ich find das einfach cool up von grafik
und wenn ihr ein iphone 6 oder 6 plus
habt ist das echt richtig hammer mit der
grafik das muss man echt sagen hier auf
dem ipad ruckelt das ganze ein bisschen
dass ein bisschen traurig aber ihr seht
schon den hier jetzt 50 prozent
zerstörung weil viele gebäude schon
zerstört habe wenngleich das piraten
versteckten geht könnt ihr rechts sehen
bei 51 prozent steht das gerade wenn das
piratenversteck taunus wird das noch mal
richtig krasser sein weil es ist genauso
wie bei klatsch of plants leute die
farben wollen stellen das versteckt
dieses dieses hauptgebäude nach draußen
damit die leute die note trophäen haben
wollen für kämpfe die dann direkt aus
hauptgebäude und jetzt seht ihr schon
direkt piratenversteck zerstört direkt
noch ein stern 27 hochgegangen
also aber der hier
bei mir ist es zurzeit wirklich so ich
gehe darauf einerseits dass man
ressourcen im mittelpunkt stehen
allerdings ganze mittelpunkt einer mine
piratenversteck also bisschen alle
branchen alle branchen aber alle
kategorien umfassen so ein bisschen
neutral wenn ich da also ich denke es
wird bei mir bald auch eine phase geben
wo ich sagen okay ich brauche unbedingt
ganz viel gold das heißt stellen meine
ganzen goldmine in die mitte und mein
goldlager so dass mir das nicht geklaut
wird und stelle meine piratenversteck
direkt nach draußen und jetzt haben wir
zum beispiel auch geschafft den kampf
jetzt freuen die sich hier ein bisschen
nur ich hatte halt alle piraten im kampf
deswegen habe ich jetzt keine mehr
übrigen muss jetzt neugierig machen
bietet gold 2008 50.000 ganz gut
zerstörungen oder prozent und 20 kampf
punkte ich bin zurzeit relativ viel am
kämpfen ihr den oben links bp das sind
die kampf punkte 368 und zwar brauche
ich sehr viel weil ich die akademie
ausbilden ausbauen will
wenn ich allerdings auf ausbilden clique
steht ja du hast ja ich hab auch zurzeit
keine freien konstrukteure aber ich
brauche 750 kampf punkte
und ich hab erst 368 also gerade mal die
hälfte und dann muss ich noch ein
bisschen viel für kämpfen
wenn jetzt quasi kam vorbei ist kann ich
hier wieder auf anheuern klicken sowie
bei kleins dann nehme ich mir hier von 3
hiervon 3 hiervon ein
hiervon nämlich immer fünf dann noch
vier diebinnen und zwei leute die also
die hexen doktoren sind die das ganze
ein bisschen offen
ja das war eigentlich schon für dieses
video stellt euch die app eigentlich nur
zeigen und schon habe ich davon ein
bisschen mehr hochladen sauberkeit auf
teilten viele packen und ich würde echt
vom großen gletscher kleins kanälen
angeschrieben die meisten hacker mir
bringen dabei aber das möchte ich nicht
werden ich möchte das ganze ein bisschen
hier alleine machen was ich euch nur als
tipp auf den weg geben kann ist quasi
eigentlich diese dekoration das machen
echt mega viele einfach nicht weil sie
denken ich brauch keine dekoration die
bringen nichts was ich allerdings findet
man kann piraten nur im wasser bauen das
heißt irgendwie hier könnte man die
spawnen allerdings nicht direkt hier
mittendrin oder hier auf dem sand
deswegen wenn ich keine dekoration hätte
dass sie sind alles dekoration diese
pflanzenkübeln dann werden die einfach
weg dann könnten die piraten nämlich
direkt hier spawnen von den gegner
deswegen habe ich hier so viele sachen
dass die piraten nur hier am rand
gespart werden können und dann hab ich
ihn entscheidenden vorteil
beispielsweise sondern kann ohne die
geht hier komplett rum
seht ihr diesen umkreis die geht bis
hierhin das heißt wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise sagen würde okay die
brauche ich alle nicht in diesen
gefangenen käfer und so könnten die hat
ihre piraten direkt aspen wo gerade die
st
gefangenen käfig ist und dann werden sie
schon viel näher an der kanone dran weiß
wisst ihr also ich versuche das ganze
ein bisschen dass die die piraten am
äußersten rand bauen müssen und dass
meine leute sich quasi meine pistole
meine kanonen und alles mögliche sich
dann direkt darauf vorbereiten die
krassesten sachen sind also der moerser
der warte ich am meisten schaden
wegen euch davon direkt zwei denn hier
muss ich auch bald mal wieder ausbauen
allerdings habe ich nur zwei
konstrukteure und ich hab keinen bock
für das spiel geld auszugeben weil ich
weiß wie viel cash die ihr schon machen
und ich muss jetzt noch fünf stunden
warten 15 stunden warten aber ich sehe
dass videos auch schon fast wieder zehn
minuten lang gesehen
ich möchte gar nicht die hucke voll
quatschen mein ablauf also das ist ein
spiel wirklich so alle drei stunden mal
rein weil ich dann sehe dass meine
piraten fertig sind und dann wieder
angreifen und dann gucke ich mal wieder
auf die karte
dass ich dann irgendwie bei erkunde die
meere hier das dann irgendwie mal dass
ich mein schiff war wieder zurückholen
und alles mögliche und ja das ist plant
ab aires gewesen wenn euch das video
gefallen
justin wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich sehr über eine bewertung
freund schreibt ein event wird und in
die kommentare welches spiel ich als
nächstes app review soll und dann sehen
wir uns in einem anderen video wieder
was eventuell heute abend eine minecraft
animation sein wird wenn die roma ich
das mal wieder gebacken kriegen aber da
kann ich nichts versprechen und deswegen
würde ich sagen sehen uns einfach nicht
einmal leute